we're shooting it much in the way that
the mandalorian series was
shot using some of that technology i
take it you're a fan of i'm a big fan of
that
that's the thing i love yeah what's up
folks carlos here lots of interesting
developments this week how often can you
say
we're gonna kick things off with some
obi-wan kenobi news chatting with
comedian eddie izzard
ewan mcgregor dropped some solid intel
on his upcoming obi-wan spin-off series
revealing that the mandalorian will be
an inspiration of sorts
when production begins this spring in
l.a
i really liked it i like the format of
it and i like the
sort of um the western nature of it like
it's an old-fashioned tv western you
know it's
brilliant i like the john favreau-ness
of it if yes
if that's a word if that's a phrase that
is a new phrase
the architect am i right now while ewan
said john will not be a part of the show
he did share how he feels about getting
back into action as obi-wan
after all these years the idea of doing
it again now is more exciting even than
it was then i think i just
i'm thrilled to get a chance to play him
again and i
i've always felt that there was that
there was a story about him between
you know my ones and alec guinness's
ones
and uh yeah that's what we're gonna do
so it should be should be really
interesting
now if you're the kind of person who
writes your own stories about your
favorite characters
dreaming that maybe one day someone's
gonna pay you for it
maybe take some inspiration from chloe
zhao the acclaimed director of nomad
land told me how her experience writing
fan fiction
compares to creating one of marvel's
biggest upcoming movies
the eternals we are really you know
reinventing a lot of these characters
it's a different process because with
fanfiction you usually have a character
that that you're so attached to that you
know for a long time
um and you try to stay within that world
i think we we
we might be pushing a bit further than
that in this case which is also a type
of fanfiction
you can go as far as you want right
speaking of the eternals angelina jolie
shared a tiny tidbit about the superhero
movie
doing a recent interview with british
vogue asked about playing finna and
wearing that gold bodysuit
angelina said quote i love this cast and
that we all came together
i signed up to support chloe's vision
and marvel's commitment to expand the
way we see
superheroes adding running around in a
gold bodysuit was not how i imagined my
40s
but it's good crazy i think that's funny
because running around in a gold
bodysuit is exactly how i picture my 40s
sorry for that mental image okay so it's
kind of hard to believe but zack
snyder's cut of the justice league is
only weeks away from being a reality
the release date march 18 is just around
the corner and news about the movie is
coming in
fast and furious this week zach released
a new image of the nightmare batman
and we now know that the four-hour film
is officially rated r
for violence and some language something
the director himself teased late last
year
promising a much more vicious
steppenwolf and a batman that doesn't
just drop smoke bombs
he drops f-bombs now a lot of people are
ready for this dark vision of their
favorite dc heroes
but even if you're not you gotta admit
the idea of ben affleck saying
i'm [ __ ] batman that's worth the price
of admission
stop right there i'm in you are and
finally don cheadle is sharing a little
bit of info about his new series armor
wars
apparently it'll explore what happens
when tony stark's tech
falls into the wrong hands and don says
quote
it's going to be dope honestly that's
all i needed i mean i knew that already
but the confirmation is nice he also
says they're going to start filming in a
couple of months so hopefully we'll be
seeing some set pictures
pretty soon i want to see all the new
armor like let's go
i'm ready do you have a favorite war
machine or iron man armor
let me know in the comments below and to
my dc people on a scale
of martha's how much better do we think
the snyder cut will be
than dawn of justice like five martha's
100 let's talk about it that's it for me
thank you for watching everyone if you
enjoyed this please like subscribe
share all that stuff we have a lot of
other videos including this week's recap
of wandavision thanks again folks i'll
see ya